prière du vendredi à la mosquée d'evry
cette banlieue parisienne est encore
sous le choc des attentats récents et
pour cause l'un des tireurs vient de
grigny la ville voisine
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui mes frères
c'est le résultat d'une méconnaissance
totale alors si l'imam a décidé de faire
de la prévention
faites attention de qui vous allez
prendre cette religion faites attention
à l'embrigadement fait attention à
l'endoctrinement je prêche n'a rien
d'étonnant ici le recteur de cette
mosquée l'une des plus grandes d'europe
est connu pour sa modération pour son
adhésion aux valeurs de la république à
musulmans vivant en france qui ne défend
pas la laïcité défaut oui la laïcité
c'est grâce à cette laïcité que j'ai pu
construire cette mosquée
khalil merroun est un allié de longue
date de manuel valls
l'actuel premier ministre français
ensemble ils ont lutté contre la
radicalisation et contre l'exclusion de
combat qui aux yeux du premier ministre
vont de pair en même temps que la lutte
contre la criminalité
les ghettos ce que j'évoquais en 2005
déjà un appart hyde territoriale sociale
ethnique qui s'est imposé à notre pays
cette formule choc de l'apartheid
français manuel valls l'a utilisé pour
la première fois alors qu'il était maire
d'evry
villenouvelle des années soixante dix
evry est l'une des nombreuses banlieues
pauvres de la couronne parisienne une
ville à la population jeune issu de
l'immigration a essentiellement de
l'afrique noire et du maghreb comme les
menaces à caveau pour tout départ que ce
tome ville connue pour ses quartiers
chauds comme une pyramide et pour ses
guerres de gangs
je les perdais ceux réputés pour être
choix ma lamine sissoko est un enfant du
quartier des pyramides à evry un
quartier dont il porte fièrement les
couleurs
tu vois avant le connu les conflits
entre quartiers tout ça on était un peu
un peu trop là dedans même
sarkozy n'est pas passée tu veux rester
en vie en traîneau centre commercial en
quelque sorte de monsieur contrôler quoi
ce territoire fallait pas un mur en mai
2006 un ami de malamine espère tour et
16 ans est tué poignardé par une bande
rivale lors d'une bataille un crime
rapidement suivie par une série de
représailles température de l'autre côté
ils ont perdu aussi
en première ligne depuis le début dans
la lutte aux guerres de gangs
des policiers sont aussi au coeur de la
stratégie de manuel valls
c'est entre quartiers du monde qui
s'affrontent l'ancien maire d'evry avait
fait de la sécurité sa priorité
dès son arrivée à la tête de la ville il
met sur pied une police de proximité
multiplient rapidement par dix le nombre
d'agents objectif décourager les
délinquants
la ville s'est également doté d'un
impressionnant système de caméras de
surveillance toutes équipées de zoom
surpuissant les quartiers sensibles sont
quadrillées et bien sûr tout est
enregistré et précis qu'à l'intérieur de
ces quartiers
oui il y à des logiques de ghettos où si
l'on n'était pas attention la vie
s'organise plus sur un mode de violence
d'insécurité de trafic que sur autre
chose que la stratégie aujourd'hui
poursuivis par le nouveau maire semble
fonctionner puisque elle a fait baissé
en dix ans de 72 % le taux de
criminalité
parallèlement la ville s'est refait une
beauté
les quartiers ont été réaménagés rénover
des fleurs ont été plantées
c'est un départ à jos ville mais selon
le maire de nouvelles politiques
sociales sont nécessaires au niveau
national pour favoriser la mixité
ce sont plutôt des logiques de
ségrégation sociale qui sont venus créer
des logiques de ségrégation territoriale
certaines initiatives locales donnent
pourtant espoir
si les jeunes se rassemblent dans ce
parking souterrain du quartier des
pyramides
ce n'est pas pour traîner ou pour
squatter mais bien pour rapide je te
marche alors mais je peux fumer tous un
peu se moquer d'eux m'a mis sur pied par
des bénévoles après la mort des sports
tourer le studio banker est aujourd'hui
un rayon d'espoir pour les jeunes du
quartier bon moyen aussi de lutter
contre la criminalité
les jeunes homos pluvieux s'ils viennent
c'est pour s'exprimer autrement que par
la dégradation de matériel que par le
vandalisme etc venir s'exprimer se
défouler par la musique pour essayer de
ne pas les faire traîner dehors les 904
écho malade
sissoko aujourd'hui mieux connu sous son
nom de rappeur malal sonne on est déjà à
son deuxième cd reste est soit la
musique où seul un délinquant ce n'était
plus tout ça oui comme quoi ça m'a
saoulé sarko au lieu d'aller voler je
sais pas quoi ou d'un juno studio râpé
aujourd'hui ma l'asean est une vedette
locale aux pyramides et le rappeur est
très conscient de son rôle de modèle
pour les plus jeunes des jeunes
confrontés comme lui aux difficultés de
la vie dans les cités du chômage quand
n'importe où mais maintenant quand
j'étais en a partout mais aussi tu vois
mais malgré ça on arrive à s'en sortir
du moins essaie de s'en sortir et
montrait même la bonne voie aux plus
jeunes à l'école tu finis par rapport à
ton diplôme
s'il reconnaît les problèmes de
discrimination manson est convaincu
qu'ils ne font pas le poids face à son
ambition à sa détermination
moi j'suis pas un sou patron gauclin de
joie toujours le bon côté des choses
tu as toujours le côté positif je suis
papa je fais tout pour l'être au maximum
dans cinq ans je me suivait
tranquillement dans ma villa à monaco